now i want to get to some absolutely
mind-blowing audio this is like an
example of
some of the worst of the worst of
corporate response to a crisis
um npr's ari shapiro interviewed
interviewed interviewed interviewed
neil potts facebook's vp for trust and
security yesterday about these documents
leaked by the whistleblower that was
exposed on 60 minutes or unveiled on 60
minutes
um the interview is fascinating because
neil potts
doesn't really deny any of the claims
doesn't really deny any of the substance
of what the whistleblower alleges but
instead seems just sort of shaken almost
like he didn't expect these were the
questions that were going to be asked he
deflects using odd language this is sort
of a clinic
in not
in how not to do crisis management so
let's just jump right in and listen here
and facebook over and over again chose
to optimize for its own interests like
making more money we'll note that the
company is among npr's financial
supporters and we're joined now by
facebook executive neil potts he is vice
president for trust and safety welcome
to all things considered buckle up here
hey ari how are you
thank you all right good to have you
here uh so how can explain facebook's
calculus this way if the company changed
the algorithm to make people safer and
deprioritized hateful and divisive posts
then people would spend less time on the
site click on fewer ads the company
would make less money do you agree that
polarization leads to engagement which
translates to money for facebook so the
argument here it's important to
understand and i'm not going to keep
interjecting but the the idea here is
although facebook publicly says we want
to depolarize we want to remove
disinformation internally they know that
that stuff generates clicks which means
money so that in reality they say one
thing publicly but they encourage this
stuff on the platform to money for
facebook
i think i'll categorically deny that i
think that accusation is uh
it's just a bit unfounded at facebook
what we are designing our products to do
is to increase it
increase meaningful experiences so
whether those are meaningful social
interactions i think that is the the
change that uh the leaker mentions in
her 60 minutes interview um or having
just positive social experience on a
platform that is what we want the
products ultimately to provide now it's
not unfounded in that there are
thousands of documents that the leaker
provided which show the opposite of what
neil potts is saying it's a environment
where people will come to facebook where
they will come to instagram and have a
just a at a better time and that's
really our bottom line so i just want to
be clear are you saying it may be the
case that polarization leads to more
engagement but we're not trying to
polarize our users so that's not what we
want the algorithm to do or are you
saying no the premise that more extreme
views will lead people to engage more is
just fundamentally wrong
i think just taking a step back on on
that question of polarization i think
polarization has you know existed long
before facebook so that's a deflection
okay the question is really specific and
and and neil pat says we didn't create
polarization that wasn't the question
neil this long after um perhaps or that
we're all
no longer here that being said at
facebook we're not designing anything to
be uh for the sensational or clickbaity
or engagement baby ways that
polarization um
may be seen and that i think was being
accused of facebook in the leadership
the guy's making absolutely no sense i
mean it just seems completely unprepared
for what were obviously going to be the
questions on the product our products
are designed to have more meaningful
social interactions those interactions
with your friends your loved ones what
does that mean close-knit groups can
ensure that you're coming to the
platform to have a just a positive
social experience one that you can have
not only just meaningful experiences but
things that you will find perhaps
unfettered
um positive
values in
you guys i hope everybody realizes this
guy's making no sense and answering none
of the questions specifically about some
of the safeguards that were put in place
after in the run-up to the 2020 election
um these were to reduce misinformation
and haugen says many of those
protections went away after the election
we now see indictments against some of
the january sixth rioters that cite
facebook posts so how does facebook
descend defend its decision to dissolve
its civic integrity unit now that you
know what happened
just after the election when some of
those safeguards were no longer in place
beautiful
thanks ari i think
i want to make sure that we're very
clear here the pacific integrity unit
has not been dissolved in any ways
actually it has been uh in many ways
promoted throughout the company the team
is now sitting with other teams so that
we can take the lessons learned so this
was a centralized team and now it's
individual responsibilities have been
farmed out to other teams
it's still within our centralized
integrity uh
i don't know that this guy says one
thing that we can actually take away
that's substantive the broader team to
focus on other issues including civic
integrity but also issues that so so
it's like what he's saying is the team
we had
has not actually been disbanded it's
just been broken up and they're now
distributed
and working on different issues well so
you've disbanded it right the the people
have been separated and they're working
on different issues and maybe also this
one issue issues that are i think at the
top of everyone's mind including uh
issues around health and in covet 19 you
can see a lot of the similarities
between the way that we treated
elections on the platform with our
elections hub as well as what we are
doing around clove at 19 and the clover
19 hub so those teams are still
in practice doing work and actually
working on civic issues and elections
the teams are still in practice doing
work
let me turn to instagram and how it
affects young people here's how haugen
characterized the company's research
last night on 60 minutes facebook's own
research says
it is not just that instagram is
dangerous for teenagers that it harms
teenagers
it's that it is distinctly worse than
other forms of social media and she says
that research found 13.5 percent of teen
girls said instagram makes thoughts of
suicide worse 17 said it worsened eating
disorders and when congress asked about
this ceo mark zuckerberg misstated the
company's research and then withheld the
damaging information that came out in
this league how does facebook justify
that
i think mark withheld any of the
research i think one of the issues here
we're you know very committed to doing
research we recognize the value so we
can close the gaps we're reducing gaps
but i want to put a bit of the context
of this research um
into the field as well
it just goes absolutely we're committed
to doing research to close gaps yeah but
that's not what the question was about
uh this research was done over a
for boys and girls of teenage years over
12 different areas and the majority
actually the majority of respondents who
are both boys and girls said that
facebook has facebook and instagram have
a net positive on their okay and of
course that's also a deflection because
the point is
many things for most people aren't
negative but if something is negative
for a lot of people it still matters and
it's still important so neil potts not
prepared
answering nothing of substance and we're
going to continue to follow what the the
the
um fallout is from this uh both from the
outage and from the whistleblower i want
to remind you tuesday october 19th at 6
pm eastern we'll be doing a david pakman
show live town hall it will be
exclusively streamed on the new david
pakman show youtube channel pacman live
which you can find at youtube.com slash
pacman live get subscribed there in
advance of the live town hall
find me on twitter let me know what you
think about this facebook stuff i'm at
deepakman on twitter
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
the link is down below